herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live es
sind furchtbare Bilder die uns heute aus
Gaza aus dem Gaza Streifen erreichen im
Hof eines Krankenhauses hat es eine
Explosion gegeben offenbar ein
Raketeneinschlag ein Sprecher des
Gesundheitsministeriums in Gaza sagt
471 Palästinenser seien getötet worden
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht und es
ist die große Frage von wem kommt diese
Rakete wer ist für diese Explosion für
diesen Raketeneinschlag verantwortlich
die Hamas und Israel schieben sich
gegenseitig die Schuld zu doch die
Reaktionen auf jeden Fall in vielen
arabischen Ländern auch in Iran sind
heftig und das wiederum hat Folgen für
die diplomatischen Bemühungen wir wollen
darüber sprechen gleich mit unserem
Israel Korrespondenten Michael Bunge und
auch mit dem ägyptischdeutschen
naostexperten Asim LD frui wenn es
Fragen Meinungen Kommentare gibt dann
einfach her damit dann können wir mit
beiden auch direkt drüber sprechen
zunächst aber ein Überblick über das was
heute geschehen ist über das was wir
wissen und auch das was wir nicht wissen
das Krankenhaus Ali Arab vor dem
Beschuss im Norden des Gazastreifens
also in der
Evakuierungszone mitten in Gaza Stadt
gestern 17:59 Uhr deutscher Zeit schlägt
eine Rakete ein von palästinensersite
israel sei verantwortlich Israel sagt
dagegen zu der Zeit habe es keine
Angriffe
gestartet weder in der Luft noch vom
Boden oder von Schiffen aus es war der
islamische Jihad der raketenabschoss
Ziel Israel eine fiel aufs
Krankenhaus die zweitgrößte bewaffnete
Gruppe in Gaza nach der Hamas eine ihre
Raketen
vigeleitet livenahmen auch vom
arabischen Fernsehen Schein das belegen
die Rakete startet so unser Faktencheck
etwas südlich vom Krankenhaus die
Flugbahn deutet darauf hin dass sie wohl
aus dem Gazastreifen gekommen ist dann
zerbricht sie offenbar in der Luft und
trifft das Hospital heimlich aufgenommen
laut Israel ein Gespräch ein hamasmglied
fragt das geschance ist es von uns sieht
so aus das Militär zeigt auch den
Einschlagsort ein Parkplatz am
Krankenhaus zu sehen zerstörte Autos
aber kein großer Krater wie sonst durch
israelische Raketen die Hamas sagt dass
Israel lügt Fakt in jedem Fall die
Klinik sie ist die einzige christliche
in
Gaza Michael beunger ist unser Israel
Korrespondent der ist Moment im Süden
Israels ganz in der Nähe zum
gazaastreifen Michael gibt es denn
inzwischen weitere neue Hinweise die
irgendwie klären könnten von wem die
Rakete stammt was wirklich in
Anführungsstrichen wahr
ist nein die israelische Seite hat ihre
Erkenntnisse offengelegt
es gibt von palästinensischer Seite
eigentlich nur dass von der Hamas
sicherlich gesteuerte
gesundheitsministerum was klar sagt das
war eine israelische Rakete es gibt
diese Rakete die auf dem Parkplatz
eingeschlagen ist offensichtlich die hat
aber auch gar keinen großen Krater
hinterlassen also das spricht nicht für
eine normal israelische Rakete die
wesentlich mehr Sprengstoff hat und
offenbar muss es aber auch irgendeine
Art von Explosion in dem Gebäude gegeben
hat was an von außen völlig intakt
erscheint denn ein Arzt berichtet dass
innendrin die Decke eingestürzt sei man
sieht von außen von Aufnahmen von heute
immer noch das intakte Gebäude ein Loch
oben im Dach aber was dann passiert ist
das ist eigentlich völlig
unklar also ergibt sich schon irgendwie
die Frage wie glaubwürdig das ganze ist
wie gesagt die Rede ist von 471
getöteten Palästinensern wenn man aber
eben nur den Parkplatz sieht es sein
mehrere hundert verletzte auch noch da
dann fragt man sich wie passt das alles
zusammen warum sollen 700 800 Menschen
da auf diesem Parkplatz im Innenhof
gewesen sein also gibt's da irgendwie
Unstimmigkeiten wie ist so dein
Bauchgefühl wie schätzt du das
ein das ist genau der Punkt also erstens
wenn eine Rakete der Israelis
eingeschlagen hätte wäre möglich erweise
das gesamte Gebäude in Schutt und Asche
gelegt worden die Raketen der Hammers
haben meistens nur eine geringere
Sprengkraft reichen eigentlich nur aus
zwei drei Räume zu zerstören aber nicht
ein ganzes Gebäude in Schutt und Asche
zu legen also die Frage ist wie kann so
ein kleiner Schaden möglicherweise von
einer kleinen Rakete so viele Verletzte
und Tote erzielt haben und umgekehrt
wenn es so viele Tote gibt dann müsste
der Schaden eigentlich viel viel größer
sein das bleibt ein eine Ungereimtheit
wir können das natürlich von hier aus
auch nicht im Detail überprüfen man kann
nur die bisher
vorliegenden Argumente und vorgelegten
Beweise bewirten also viele
Ungereimtheiten aber wir stellen ja fest
diese Bilder die wir aus dem
gaserastreifen da zu sehen bekommen sie
gehen um die Welt und sie rufen eben
gewisse Reaktionen hervor wir können uns
das einfach mal anschauen es gibt viele
kritische Reaktionen für viele der
arabischen Welt in Iran Irak etc steht
fest Israel
ist es
der diese Rakete abgeschossen hat und
über diese Wut berichtet Anna
Feist sie sind wütend deshalb wollen sie
nicht von der Straße lassen nicht mehr
aufhören zu protestieren hier in
Jordanien sowie in vielen anderen
arabischen Ländern seit vergangener
Nacht seit den ersten Berichten über den
Angriff auf das Krankenhaus in Gaza wird
zum Sturm aufgerufen im Libanon Sturm
auf die amerikanische Botschaft in
birut wir sind hier damit die Araber
endlich aufwachen Freiheit für Palästina
Israel im Irak Sturm auf die Green Zone
in Bagdad dort wo die westlichen
Botschaften angesiedelt sind ihre
sprechköre haben eine eindeutige
Nachricht an den Westen hau ab Israel
hau ab Amerika denn für die arabische
Welt steht fest israel hat die Rakete
abgefeuert auf das Krankenhaus und auch
das manifestiert sich spätestens in
dieser Nacht mit Israel sitzt der
gesamte Westen auf der
Anklagebank so wird seine Mission zur
Mission Impossible Kanzler Scholz
erreicht nach seinem Besuch in Israel am
Dienstagabend Kairo hier will er
verhindern dass es zu einem Flächenbrand
in der Region kommt so folgt eine
mitleidsbekundung dann eine Mahnung vom
Kanzler noch wissen wir nicht genau was
passiert ist es ist wichtig dass dieser
vtfall sehr genau aufgeklärt wird doch
ob solche Worte durchdringen zu denen
die voller Zorn die Straßen stirmen
unwahrscheinlich angesichts der szhen
die sich gerade wieder in Jordanien im
Libanon und im Irak
abspielen Michael du hast es gesagt der
Kanzler hat es gesagt wir wissen noch
nicht genau was wirklich passiert ist
von wem die Rakete exakt also kommt doch
diese Bilder zeigen ja Wirkung ist das
auch ein Beweis dafür dass wir hier ja
einen Krieg der Bilder haben dass
Propaganda eben Wirkung
zeigt ja wir haben h ganz eindeutig
neben dem physischen Krieg am Boden
einen Propagandakrieg im Netz äh in den
Nachrichten und der folgt anderen
Gesetzen schon gestern also wenige
Minuten als eigentlich noch niemand
wusste was überhaupt passiert ist auch
wir haben sofort versucht das zu
recherchieren konnten das zumindest
nicht so eindeutig klären wie das äh
einige in der arabischen Welt schon
konnten gab es sofort in allen Staaten
äh äh die Verurteilungen ganz klar das
ist Israel das muss Israel gewesen sein
obwohl es mindestens berechtigte Zweifel
gibt und heute nach 24 Stunden
mindestens noch deutlich mehr
berechtigte Zweifel also es verwundert
wie schnell diese
Vorverurteilung stattfindet es zeigt
aber auch dass faktisch Israel kaum eine
Chance hat diesen Propagandakrieg
zumindest in der muslimischen arabischen
Welt zu gewinnen denn dort ist ganz klar
israel ist der Feind und Israel sind
alle Vorgänge hier in Gaza
zuzuschreiben jetzt hat das ganze ja
eben auch Folgen für die Diplomatie
eigentlich sollte es heute einen Gipfel
oder sollte es einen Gipfel in Jordanien
geben US-Präsident Biden der in Israel
eingetroffen ist sollte weiter nach
Jordanien um sich dort zu treffen mit
dem Palästinenserführer aus dem
Westjordanland Abbas mit alsisi und
jordani
König Abdullah nun wurde dieser Gipfel
von Abdullah abgesagt vielleicht
verschoben
was bedeutet das letzten Endes dass hier
die Diplomatie ja sozusagen in Stolpern
gerät und was bedeutet das eben auch für
beiden der nach Israel gekommen ist ja
aber auch etwas bewegen wollte auf dem
diplomatischen
Paket also ich glaube man sollte die
Erfolgschancen dieses möglichen Gipfels
nicht zu sehr überladen denn ob da
tatsächlich konkrete Ergebnisse
rausgekommen wären das sei mal
dahingestellt aber natürlich ist das
eine Schlappe von beiden dass ihn die
arabischen Führer brüskieren so hat er
nur den Besuch in Israel dort immerhin
hat er sein Minimalziel erreicht premier
Netanyahu hat ihm persönlich zugesagt
dass er alles tun werde bei der weiteren
Kriegsführung um Schäden Schaden von der
Zivilbevölkerung abzuwenden und er hat
endlich offiziell zugestimmt dass es
über einen humanitären Korridor von
Ägypten aus Hilfslieferungen in den
Gazastreifen gehen geben kann bisher
haben wir zwar noch keine Bestätigung
dass diese Grenze bei Raffa zwischen
Gaza und Ägypten tatsächlich auf ist auf
der einen Seite warten noch immer die
Lastwagen auf der anderen Seite warten
viele ausländische Staatsbürger die
ausreisen wollen bisher ist noch keine
offizielle Freigabe aus Ägypten erfolgt
nur so viel ist klar ägypten will auf
gar keinen Fall Flüchtlinge aus Ägypten
aufnehmen also Palästinenser aus Gaza
und die ausländischen Staatsbürger sind
wohl gehalten möglichst zügig das Land
wieder zu
verlassen Michael eine Frage die man
sich jeden Tag ja irgendwie stellt die
Vorbereitungen für eine Bodenoffensive
für eine offensive
sind von der israelischen Armee
getroffen worden es gab ja auch mal ein
24 Stunden Ultimatum das ist verstrichen
dann hieß es schlechtes Wetter wie steht
es denn um diese Offensive gibt es von
den israelischen Streitkräften
irgendwelche Hinweise Andeutungen dass
die unmittelbar bevorsteht oder kann
sich das auch noch weiter
hinausziehen nein diese Offensive war
bereits am vergangenen Wochenende
komplett vorbereitet am Samstag
da G ging es das evakuierungs äh die
evakuierungsaufforderung der
Streitkräfte zu Ende dass die Menschen
Gaza verlassen sollten Gaza Stadt den
Norden das ist soeit zu hörenes
weitgehend Erfolg eine Million Menschen
soll aus dem Norden geflüchtet sein
wir haben gestern noch große hunderte
Panzer Aufmärsche im direkt im Norden
von Gaza gesehen also Israels Armee ist
bereit betont das auch immer wieder
trotzdem wird auch hier in Israel viel
darüber spekuliert warum denn dann wenn
alles bereit ist und Netanyahu immer
wieder erklärt die hamass wird
vollständig zerschlagen werden das geht
ja nur mit einer Bodenoffensive warum
diese Offensive noch nicht gestartet ist
ich würde sagen sie ist nicht vom Tisch
vor allem nach der Abreise von Joe Biden
ist wahrscheinlicher dass sie jetzt
demnächst startet aber momentan ist sie
offenbar noch auf halten gesetzt dann
danken wir ganz herzlich für die ganz
frischen Information und auch die
Einschätzungen Michael bwerunger im
Süden Israels nahe des Gazastreifens
vielen dank Michael ja wenn wir den
gesamten Konflikt vergleichen mit einem
großen Schachbrett dann gibt es neben
der und Israel noch viele andere Figuren
vielleicht auch größere Figuren auf
diesem Schachbrett und jemand der viele
dieser Figuren dieser Player sehr gut
kennt ist der ägyptischdeutsche
Politologe und nostexperte assim l di
frui ih erreichten wir jetzt in Berlin
schönen guten Abend und danke dass Sie
dabei sind gleichfalls schönen guten
Abend her die Frau was sagen sie zu der
Explosion bei diesem Krankenhaus zu dem
möglichen Raketenbeschuss des
Krankenhauses im kasstreifen zu den
Bildern die sie ja auch gesehen haben
also wie gesagt es gibt viele Zweifel es
ist schwer im Moment ein Urteil zu
fällen aber eines ist klar
es gab Tote unter der Zivilbevölkerung
generell wird die Anzahl der Toten
fallalls Israel diese Offensive machen
wird diese Bodenoffensive und die wird
vermutlich stattfinden wird die Anzahl
der Toten eben in Gaza wirklich in die
Höhe schnellen und natürlich durch
übertragende Bilder durch diese so
schnell auf sozialen Netzwerk
verweiteten Bilder für Zorn in der
arabischen Welt führen wichtig ist dann
wirklich jetzt im Moment aufzuklären äh
wie es zu dem Zwischenfall in dem
Krankenhaus kam und vielleicht probieren
soweit wie möglich die arabische
Öffentlichkeit davon überzeugen dass
nicht nur Israel für diese Toten
verantwortlich sind aber natürlich kann
man sich ä in den nächsten Wochen drauf
einstellen dass ä die arabische
Öffentlichkeit natürlich auch nicht zu
Unrecht sondern zurecht ä sich darüber
beklagen wird wie viel
palästinensische ähm palästinensische
zivilbevölkerungs wie viele
palästinensische Kinder und Frauen
sterben werden ähm und
m jetzt müssen wir halt sollten wir
darauf achten dass ä
wir den Palästinensern auf der
diplomatischen Ebene einfach so viel
Unterstützung wie möglich geben dass
vielleicht dieser Zorn ein bisschen
bisschen abgeschwächt werden kann und
natürlich klar darstellen dass
hamasß für die aktuellen
Aktionen für die aktuelle israelische
Offensive verantwortlich ist immer
wieder das zu betonen weil auch
zahlreiche Palästinenser und sehr viele
Araber befürworten in keinster Weise
Hamas und seinen
Terror jetzt ein Punkt den wir gerade
mit Michael bberunge besprochen haben es
ist ja auch ein Krieg der Bilder
Propaganda auch die Israelis waren ja
eigentlich in der Vergangenheit eher
zurückhaltend wenn es darum ging Bilder
zu zeigen von Verletzten Israelis oder
toten Israelis jetzt zeigen sie aber
auch welches Massaker die Hamas am 7
Oktober angezettelt
hat wie sieht das aus ist es wirklich
eine Schlacht der Bilder fallen da auch
gewisse Tabus versucht jede Seite die
Deutungshoheit da zu gewinnen natürlich
jede militärische Konfrontation wird
propagandistisch und vor allen Dingen im
unserem Zeitalter medial über die
sozialen Medien von Anfang an mitgedacht
Hamas hat versucht seinen spektakulären
Angriff von Anfang an zu filmen diese
Bilder davon zu verbreiten die
drohenangriffe zu zeigen und ist dann
natürlich
leider oder zum Glück ist dann leider in
erbärmliche Grausamkeiten verfallen um
eben noch die Bilder des Terrors
zu zeigen eben diese zivilen Opfer die
die Weltöffentlichkeit geschockt haben
ähm und da scheint Herm z.B das eigene
Bild oder das was sie kommunizieren
wollen nicht kontrolliert zu nicht mehr
kontrollieren zu haben weil diese
Grausamkeiten die von den heraskämpfern
begangen begangen worden sind natürlich
auch ähm der dem Ansehen von Hamas in
der arabischen Welt Schaden Israel
scheint seinerseits von einer alten
Praxis sich allmählich wegzub beewegen
das israelische Militär hat ja früher
sehr wenig Opfer gezeigt auch ähm ähm
sehr wenige Zivilopfer wurden gezeigt
also nicht explizit gezeigt aber um eben
die Weltöffentlichkeit davon zu
überzeugen dass
Hamas da wirklich unannehmbare
Grausamkeiten verbracht hat ist Israel
von dieser alten Praxis abgerückt zeigte
auch tote Soldat
zeigte zeigte die Grausamkeiten an den
die an den Kindern verbracht worden sind
also in dieser visuellen Konfrontation
die natürlich auch vor allen Dingen
mittlerweile so direkt so schnellbig ist
das heißt man innerhalb von Sekunden
sind Sachen auf den sozialen Medien zu
sehen da bekämpfen sich natürlich beide
Seiten weiterhin besonders extrem jetzt
haben sie ja auch deutlich gemacht die
Bilder haben ja trotzdem eben eine
Wirkung wir haben es eben im Beitrag
auch gesehen jede Menge teste
in der arabischen Welt in Jordanien
im Irak aber auch Iran ähm das ganze
scheint ja wohl eben auch die
Regierungschefs die Präsidenten unter
Druck zu setzen denn Abdullah i i König
von Jordanien hatte ja eigentlich
geladen zu einem Gipfel da sollte Abbas
da sollte Assisi und Joe Biden mit
teilnehmen nun ist das Ganze abgesagt
man könnte auch sagen vielleicht
verschoben worden zeigt das irgendwie
dass es da eine gewisse Angst gibt vor
dieser Meinung in der eigenen
Öffentlichkeit der eigenen Bevölkerung
natürlich müssen diese relativ
autoritären Herrscher am gewissen Punkt
auf die ihre öffentliche Meinung
Rücksicht nehmen gerade in Jordanien die
jordanische Bevölkerung spä besteht zu
über 60% aus
palätinendisstämmigen Menschen
und da sind natürlich ganz große
Sympathien für das Leiden der
Palästinenser da in Ägypten ist es
ähnlich da gibt es natürlich nicht so
viele ursprüngliche palästinensische aus
palästiner stammende Ägypter aber
trotzdem muss auch CC sehr auf die
öffentliche Meinung achten und wenn
jetzt angenommen wird es gab so viele
zivile Toten zunächst mal ein schr
Schritt zurückzugehen und sagen man wird
sich nicht sofort mit dem arabischen
Präsidenten treffen langfristig haben
müssen sowohl Jordanien als auch
Ägypten natürlich mit den Amerikanern
reden beide sind von amerikanischer
Hilfe abhängig Ägypten natürlich enorm
von amerikanischer Militärhilfe da sind
die Amerikaner der größte Geber
überhaupt und man muss natürlich auch
mit dem Amerikanern eine Lösung für die
humanitäre Situation im Gazastreifen
finden ab gewissen Punkt werden wieder
alle miteinander reden müssen auch mit
Abbas von der palästinensischen
palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde wie
weit der noch Kredibilität hat ist
natürlich eine ganz große Frage aber ich
glaube es W jetzt erstmal taktisch zu
taktisch ein taktischer Zug zu sagen wir
reden nicht mit Joe B aber langfristig
ist natürlich diesen arabischen
Machthabern auch klar dass sie mit den
Amerikanern sehr intensiv
kooperieren kooperieren müssen um diee
Situation zu deeskalieren und vor allen
Dingen auch die humanitäre Situation zu
deeskalieren jetzt haben sie ja eben
auch Ägypten angesprochen wir haben
gesprochen über die Situation ja auch
der Menschen die aus dem Norden des
gasastreifens in den Süden schon mal
geflohen sind gewechselt sind die große
Frage ist wie soll die Versorgung
ausgehen bisher hat ja
Ägyptens Präsident als Sisi gesagt nein
bloß keine Palästinenser ins eigene Land
reinlassen hat Joe Biden bei seinem
Besuch in Israel heute etwas bewirkt in
dieser Frage der Versorgung der Menschen
die dort eben im Gazastreifen im
südlichen Teil sind wenn die Grenzen ja
bisher geschlossen
sind das kann ich so noch nicht direkt
sagen aber auf i zumindest hat hat er ja
Zugeständnisse abbringen können an die
von der israelischen Regierung in es
darum geht es die Palästinenser
nicht vertrieben werden sollen dass ä
dass der die Zivilgesellschaft beschützt
werden soll und damit kann man ja auch
davon ausgehen dass
in gewisser Weise humanitäre Hilfe
diskutiert wird entscheidend ist aber
wiederum jetzt zu dieser Zeit die
Haltung Ägyptens die Ägyptens behaupten
dass sie an diesem Grenzübergang Rafa im
Moment keine Hilfsgüter liefern können
weil auf Israel weil auf die israelister
da bombardieren würden das halte ich
jetzt für nicht sehr wahrscheinlich mir
scheint es dass die Ägypter weitere
Zugeständnisse haben wollen von den
Amerikanern aber auch von den Israelis
dass eben keine Palästinenser über die
Grenze kommen äh es wird ja intensiv
darüber verhandelt dass zumindest ähm
ähm Palästinenser die mehrere
Staatsangehörigkeiten haben und
ausländische Staatsbürger jetzt nach
Ägypten reingelassen werden und über
Raffa evakuiert werden ich glaube hinter
den Kulissen wird gerade ganz intensiv
verhandelt die Ägypter haben natürlich
auch eine ganz große Angst dass
verzweifelte Palästinenser also 100ta000
und sowas ist vor ein paar Jahren schon
mal passiert da waren es tausende den
Grenzau nach Ägypten stürmen
und sich dann in Ägypten niederlassen
und die ägyptische Arme da
in eine verzweifelte Lage bringen weil
wenn die Lage sich so im Gaza so
zustützt wo sollen denn die
Palästinenser hin sie können eigentlich
nur nach Ägypten und wenn dann irgendwie
10 000 Palästinensern probieren über die
Grenze kommen was machen die Ägypter
dann ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
die ägyptische Armee dann auf
auf palästinänische Frauen und Kinder
schießen wird also Ägypter ist großen
Dilemma und muss sich nachdem es Joe
Biden heute gesnoppt hat trotzdem
bewegen und was machen also knifflige
Situation im Süden des
gazaastreifens schauen wir einfach auch
noch mal in einen ander auf einen
anderen Punkt Dani schreibt über Youtube
stellt die Frage wie ist die aktuelle
Lage im
Westjordanland und an den Grenzen
Israels abseits oder in der Nähe des zum
Libanon wir haben heute gehört hört dass
es auch wieder Attacken auf Israel von
der hisbolla ausgegeben hat sind das
Nadelstiche ist das
ja ein wirkliches Eingreifen in den
Konflikt wie ist eben genau die Lage
dort im Norden Israels mit hisbolla im
Libanon und im
Westjordanland also ich habe viel mit
libanesischen Kollegen gesprochen
und die sind auch der Einschätzung wir
können uns da auch täuschen dass bisher
die hzbollah nur
symbolisch ähm zeigt ä mit kleinen
Angriffen eben mit diesen nadelnstichen
dass äh sie sich mit Heras solidarisiert
ähm Hisbollah äh nach der amerikanischen
Machtdemonstration also
Flugzeugträger diipomatie und dem
Aufmarsch also dies der der
amerikanischen Flotte im östlichen
Mittelmeer weiß sehr genau äh was
passieren kann und was es für ein Risiko
eingeht falls ähm falls ähm es wirklich
Israel angreifen sollte also ich und
meine libanesischen Kollegen z. halten
wirkliche Eskalation von Seiten Hals
bollers ähm im Moment für nicht sehr
wahrscheinlich die große Frage ist
natürlich was wird der Iran machen wird
der Iran probieren hzbollah anzustacheln
oder wird der Iran probieren direkt
Israel anzugreifen aber dem Iran ist
auch klar dass ä in dem Falle
Amerika doch mit mit ganz großer mit
ganz großen Mittel und Gewalt
zurückschlagen würde also in dieser
nördlichen Front in Anführungsstrichen
hat halten viele Beobachter im Moment
eine Eskalation die kann passieren
Moment nicht für wahrscheinlich das
westlord Land gibt natürlich da gibt es
viel viel Grund zur Unruhe die
palästinensischen Autorität unter Mahmud
Abbas ist sehr geschwächt da haben Hamas
Hamas Sympathisanten sogar den in
anführungstrchen den Präsidentenpalast
angegriffen es wurde von den palchen
sicherheitsbörden zurück
zurückgeschossen die palästinensische
Autorität also die Übergangs die aut die
Chefs dieser autonomen Regierung haben
kaum noch Kredibilität unter der
Bevölkerung Hamas ist bei jungen
Palästinensern dort auch nicht beliebt
die große Frage ist überhaupt wer soll
denn gerade im westjland wer kann
effektiv
die Palästinenser repräsentieren was
wird denn überhaupt passieren mit ä
palästinensische Autonomie wenn sich der
Nebel des Krieges in gasalan irgendwann
mal gelichtet hat also ganz ganz große
Fragen
in Sachen Palästinenser deren
Gesellschaft wer sind da die
Ansprechpartner wird es überhaupt mal
möglich wieder sein zwischen
israelischen palästinändern zu reden
weil auch wenn Hamas in der jetzigen
Form zerstört wde irgendwann das sagen
auch
wichtige israelische Generäle die in der
israelischen Politik unter irgendwann
müssen auch mal dauerhafte Lösungen
gefunden werden
wie es
in Palästina weiter gehen soll und die
nächste Frage wer Frage sozusagen die
nächste wer frrage die stellen beide
Danny über Youtube und auch Sven odendah
ich fass das mal zusammen Danny schreibt
inwiefern kann die EU hier als
Vermittler auftreten zwischen den
Parteien ist Ägypten dann wohl der
höchstwahrscheinliche Vermittler genau
wie in der Vergangenheit und Sven
odendall schreibt welcher Staat kann
denn überhaupt Einfluss auf die
Konfliktparteien nehmen um die
Kriegshandlungen zu beenden das ist
sozusagen sie haben es deutlich gemacht
der erste Schritt Kriegshandlungen zu
beenden Konflikt aber langfristig zu
lösen und eine Zukunft aufzubauen da ist
eben auch die Frage wer kann das machen
und wie soll das geschehen also Ägypten
hat in der Vergangenheit
zwischen Hamas und den Israelis
teilweise vermitteln können da ging es
vor allen Dingen um humanitäre Fragen
es kann jetzt auch so sein dass ägpten
nur in dem Sinne vermittelt dass es
Israelis bittet die diese und diese
Bevölkerungsgruppen das heißt entweder
Frauen und Kinder auszureisen
Ägypten
Rolle beschränkt sich aber zur Zeit
darauf weil
es wird tatsächlich so sein oder scheint
uns doch sehr wahrscheinlich dass die
israelische bodenofensive stattfinden
wird und Hamas in der jetzigen Form
zerstört wird also zwischen Hamas und
Israel kann keiner vermitteln viel
interessanter ist eine langfristige
vermitteln wer schafft es ich meine die
EU ist ein ganz großer
Geldgeber in der palästinensischen
Gesellschaft Stimmen zu finden die mit
der EU auch arbeiten würden die von der
EU abhängig ähm um Palästinenser die
eben nicht Hamas Hamas Radikale sind
sondern eine moderate gesiedelschaft wen
kann mit wen kann die EU da
helfen
unterstützen um irgendwann mit den
Israelis zu verhandeln wir wissen ja
auch gar nicht
wie wie sich israelische Politik wenn
diese gewaltige Konfrontation erstmal
beendet ist und das kann ja noch Wochen
und Monate daen wie sich israelische
Politik verändern wird werden da
hartliner an der Macht bleiben
Rechtspopulisten oder ZAT rechtsextreme
oder wird dieses Umfeld von yatanaau der
auch natürlich in Israel sehr kritisiert
wird als Premierminister wird es von der
Macht durch ein
ang vertrieben werden dann wieder
moderate Israelis die eben wie berühmte
Generäle sagen irgendwann müssen wir
doch wieder mit den Palästinensern reden
das sind alles diese großen
ungewichtweiten aber gerade ähm da
sollten die EU und Deutschland drauf
vorbereiten was passiert in dem
nachhamas also äußerst schwierig das
machen sie ja zumindest deutlich was die
Zukunft angeht da haben wir nicht die
Kristallkugel und das wird eben auch
sehr schwer sein bleiben wir aber noch
mal bei dem ganz ganz ganz dringenden
nahelegenden Problem was ich eben stell
sie haben gesagt die Bodenoffensive sie
lässt sich nicht verschieben oder
kenzeln um Hamas eben zu beseitigen die
Macht zu nehmen muss es wohl die
Bodenoffensive geben Israel ist
vorbereitet und kann da wohl nicht drum
herum aber was ist mit den Geiseln die
eben noch in der Hand sind ist das so
dass Israel am Ende sagt die müssen wir
dann in Kauf nehmen oder verzögert sich
das Ganze ähm wird die Hamas
ausländische Geiseln als Faustpfand auch
in der Situation bei einer
Bodenoffensive behalten oder hat Hamas
irgendeine Motivation zu sagen die
ausländischen Geiseln die lassen wir
wenigstens frei damit wir irgendwie doch
noch äh gute Beziehungen äh zum Ausland
haben wie sehen Sie das
Ganze ich glaube gute Beziehung zum
westlichen Ausland Wirte Hamas kaum mehr
haben aber die die die europäischen
Geisen und die amerikanischen Geisel
sind natürlich ein faustfand mit dem man
z.B humanitäre Hilfe für die Gaza
verhandeln kann ne und da bestehen
wahrscheinlich ganz große Chancen dass
da im Moment sogar drüber gesprochen
wird wann wann werden europäische
darunter auch deutsche und französische
Geiseln freigelassen und amerikanische
um zumindest
für Gaza humanitäre
Erleichterung
herzustellen das ganz große Thema ist
dass Israel bisher eine Politik hatte wo
jeglicher Israeli als Geisel
befreit werden
sollteit werden musste selbst die
Leichen von Toten
Israelis von Soldaten ähm
zurückgeholt werden müssen und zwar
gegen enorme Zugeständnisse wir erinnern
uns von ein paar Jahren hat Herm über
1200 der eigenen Kämpfer aus
israelischen Gefängnissen
herauserpressen können für einen
einzigen israelischen Soldaten da glaubt
hab glaubt her auch Herm glaubte wohl
auch jetzt vor dieser
Geiselnahme dass die Israelis enorme
Zugeständnisse machen tausende von Hamas
Gefangenen freilassen noch weit weitere
Zugeständnisse machen aber in der
israelischen Politik wird ganz offen
diskutiert dass diese Politik eben kein
Geiseln zurückzulassen sondern alle
Geiseln zu zu befreien oder sich auf
schwierige Verhandlungen und
Zugeständnisse einzulassen dass diese
Politik vielleicht ein Ende neim und ein
trauriger Realismus eingesetzt hat dass
man eben nicht alle Geiseln befreien
kann sondern
dass man mit Waffengewalt gegen Hamas
und gegen alle geilenmer vorgehen muss
auch wenn dabei bedautlicherweise
Geiseln sterben können um eben in der
Zukunft abzuschrecken und klar zumachen
ähm dass wenn Geiseln genommen werden
die Geiselnehmer nichts erpressen können
Amerika hat z.B eine Politik im
Gegensatz zu z.B europäischen Mächten
z.B Frankreich Amerika verhandelt
grundsätzlich mit keinem
Geiselnehmer niemals und zahlt auch kein
zahlt auch z.B kein
Lösegeld Frankreich oder so macht das
anders es könnte ja sein dass ich Israel
ähm langfristig vielleicht eher um
abzustrecken diese amerikanischen
Position annähert so schwierig es ist
sie sagen es so schwierig es ist auf dem
diplomatischen Paket etwas zu erreichen
sich für die Geiseln einzusetzen wir
haben die Bilder gesehen der Kanzler ist
nach Ägypten geflogen da wird das auch
das Thema sein die Versorgung der
Menschen im südlichen Gazastreifen die
dorthin geflohen sind ja und
letztenendes auch zu klären was heute
oder was gestern viel mehr passiert ist
eben mit dies Klinik und gleichzeitig
einzuwirken auf diejenigen die derzeit
schon vorverurteilen und laut
protestieren wir sagen großes Danke
schön für ihre Einschätzungen assim l
die fraui vielen Dank nach Berlin und
wünschen Ihnen auch gute Gespräche die
sie in Berlin führen werden was eben
auch das weitere Prozedere angeht vielen
Dank und Grüße nach Berlin ja und ich
sage auch vielen Dank an alle die Fragen
Kommentare und Meinungen geschickt haben
vielen Dank für das Interesse tschüss
und auf
Wiedersehen